bene del ragazzo che sono ritornato in
famiglia oggi stiamo sul no no no non è
questo il titolo che cazzo è neanche
questo è il titolo super cioè andiamo su
superciak che sarebbe un videogioco
strano
ragazzi io capisco che i giochi indie
non ci hanno budget quindi sono fatti un
po così però porca trovare ma fatelo in
un cazzo di albero nel menu livello 1
trento ragazzino che similissimo a super
8 certamente uguale non so ragazzi si è
fatto dagli stessi creatori di super hot
perché è uguale cibo è uguale nel senso
le cose sono rosse e sono grosse come in
super hot e prima che bisogna saltare da
un camion all'altro magari non farsi
investire da un camion
subito dopo averci saltato sopra
saltando da un camion all'altro arrivare
al traguardo che sta alla fine minchia o
lunghe ragazzi la particolarità di
questo videogame che se state fermi cioè
io adesso soffermo vara lenti come in
super 8 che c'è veramente uguale al
super 8 secondo me è fatto agli stessi
creatori ma che è impossibile tanto
sanno io non capisco penso cagate in
mano abbiamo appena può cristo ma potete
guidare così come dei deficienti
cerebrolesi abbiamo appurato che chi
guida questi camion sono sicuramente
delle scimmie ubriache
ce la faranno i nostri eroi a
raggiungere il traguardo prima che la
vicenda è la madonna sono fatto non ci
credo sì ma ragazzi andate dritto ce la
fai ad andare interrotto ma non quel
coso che hai davanti si chiama sasso e
si evita niente un gatto proprio ma
allora ciao ragione l'uomo dai creatori
in super 8
ve lo giuro che non lo sapremo mai lo
giuro era troppo uguale al super hot per
non essere super 8 ragazzino comunque
successo perché si stanno ingrossando
due camion state assistendo ragazzi
all'accoppiamento di due camion e una
cosa che non si vede tutti i giorni devo
saltare sul camion con la mamma quello
che è stato inglobato dio cosa succede
due sono anche sui gay come cazzo ci
arrivò la giunta salto sui pezzi lidi
cosi funziona è però qualcuno può far
avvicinare un camion che ci salta sopra
per colpi niente i camion sono andati a
[ __ ]
per favore qualcuno che eccoli oddio
mica vista schiacciata non mi ha
schiacciato perfetta lega dovesse andare
dritti bravo no no si no oddio le uscite
non è possibile
si no
oddio
un ragazzo creatori di super 8 sono
fantastici e fanno roba epica ma sapete
cosa vuol dire epica tranquillo 0 mi
chiedo ma come fanno dei camion che
vanno dritti a cappottarsi come le
deficienze ma come penso fanno non sono
vivo livello 5 quanto ha denunciato
giorno
non lo so io vado avanti ragazzi finché
non muoio l'amateur la cosa che salta ho
fatto un certo punto ho fatto un salto
chilometrico è impossibile sul serio c'è
incredibile oddio ma perché vai store ma
perché scusa se tocco terra muoio c'è
qual è il motivo non ho capito io sto
qua che sono l'uomo che non può toccare
terra ma può camminare solo sui camion
questa mia nuova ragazza dio non aveva
mentre gamma siete veramente scimmie
ubriache ma come cazzo fatta guidare
così ma manco io comincio a patente
guido così è
ma ragazzi ma se sto fermo su un camion
succede con ho mai visto third no vabbè
zio ma puoi ma puoi essere così ubriaco
mano male poi andare al pub è come se
non fosse abbastanza difficile ragazzi
dorna bella lì non ha seriamente che
fornello
le pare non c'avevo proprio dubbi che me
lo sarei pigliata dentro il naso non
avevo neanche un dubbio so perché i
ragazzi mi metto un sacco di anni però
stai calmo ma che li mette veramente
tanta ansia sto gioco non lo so perché
non ci ha presi per miracolo
io sto fermo sei pensato questa la fila
giusta non ci metterà mai perfetto
perfetto vai vai bravo bravate tanda la
patente solo a te per il cristiano che
sa guidare i sto già uno per l'amor di
dio ragazzi sono gli alberi più belli
che io abbia mai visto in un videogame
volano pietre quel problema perché che
cazzo succede ma come acer un salto da
un salto quindi a un certo punto saltano
nel vuoto bello so magari ragazzi con
aste il pavimento porca [ __ ] magari lo
vedrei il salto non si vede niente se
non solo camion che saltano a casini ma
mica che cambiano presi in bocca
lo so che avete tante domande ma voi non
fatemi l'este domanderà passati dal
quinto al tredicesimo e poi dal
tredicesimo al diciassettesimo perché il
per colmo di perché salta i livelli
perché ci sono i salti per l'amor di dio
che già non riesco ad andare avanti
normale e vabbè che purissimo sono
deficiente deficiente allora frate
capiamoci no oggi o non hai capito un
cazzo
no ma porca vacca ma dai
sì sì sì cognone madonna lo presi in
faccia il camion prossimo vivo non so
come non ho idea di come sia possibile
c'è un albero e zio uno solo cene bravo
complimenti
magari passo giusto cammino un po meglio
che vive perfetto una ragazza l'ha fatta
anche lui grazie a dio non si sa come e
perché c'era un albero l'ha preso in
faccia solo quello genera pasta
mi sto scassato le pa livello 21
saltiamo a livelli così a caso tanto ma
perché traguardo è lì a dovete fare la
curva ma ci manca solo quello ward è
certo non avevo dubbi sono diventato una
ruota
per quale motivo dei camion dovrebbero
arrivare oddio preso un albero in piazza
sono vivo posso stare sugli alberi ma
non per terra ragazzi non so perché non
so con quale legge fisica però posso
stare sugli alberi già qualcosa
ciao zio zio non hai capito un pesce
perché sei deficiente dai frate c'è un
cazzo di albero crociera un albero 1 dai
ma può e volevo provare a fare il salto
manco quello ovviamente per vincere il
suo livello mi devo aggrappare agli
alberi manco fosse una scimmia io
veramente dopo c'è stato il diversi sono
aperte le acque come mosè mosè ha aperto
le acque io ho aperto i camion da
vincere questo livello e beccarsi
l'albero in facciata
dopo in faccia piena perfetto perché no
perfetto ok se riesce ad andare dritto
mi fa in favore zio che è bravissimo vai
zio vai dritto dritto dritto devi solo
andare dritto devi solo andare dritto i
top si storto ma quanto sono ubriachi sì
o no e lo zio no gen
sì sì sì credo era andato fuori ma mi
sono buttato dentro va bene va bene va
bene va bene non fate domande va beh
oddio dove vado calmi ma ok perfetto
madonna che bordello
guardate che casino posso saltare
sull'edificio troppo dio l'ho preso ci
sono sopra ma come no no no no no fermi
che mi serve di cavi o sporca rai da lo
sapevo e ho fatto una gran cosa c'è
l'edificio aiuta dal se rischio c salto
di moso no vabbè zio ma se in deficiente
ma come come fa ma dai ma pardon prova
su di me poter scegliere altro camion o
è ok no così ci sta la galleria sotto ce
la posso fare me lo sento stavolta
quella buona
stavolta quella buona non ci posso
credere in credito e pausa pugno non
manca gatto qualcosa mi dice che non
manca crema dove il traguardo sedimenta
eccolo napoli sono altri camion dove sta
il traguardo il suo livello di merda
sì dai dai dai dai dai dai dai vari non
lo vedo traguardo proprio a baci baci
dai non ci posso credere si no non è
vero non è vero non è vero mi incazzo
aiuta
no dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai
ragazzi dai dai cielo olga per l'ultima
e non è possibile
dopo davanti all'edificio che mi sono
schiantato io è per carità non un altro
come fanno a cadere con gli edifici
quest'altra devo farne possibile fatti
spazio fatti largo vai uomo vai uomo vai
uomo guida uomo guida dai che cazzo ecco
di che incredibile ma quanto ci ho messo
non potete capire
dio mio 41 41 livello 41 eravamo al 27
come impossibile ma questo poco fascino
una sola volta scommettere che è stato
uscito dalla carreggiata de fori è
uscito dio
bravo ma veramente cioè 27 era
impossibile questo ma lo ha fatto in una
volta sola
posso ancora un po troppo presto per
dirlo però ci provo
ragazzuoli ormai non c'è più verso buono
ragazzi dire che come primo episodio
posso concludere qui anche perché non so
quanti livelli ci siano quindi magari ne
faccio un altro ma veramente fighissimo
il problema che fai incazzare ma giusto
ragazzi ve lo consiglio a un bel
passatempo saltare sui camion se vi
capita fa non è figo sicuro ragazzi
concluso che l'episodio servito è
piaciuto ha setacciato momento è un mi
piace anche la voce di facebook è come
il vino tata notizia nei sensi di sky
noi ci vediamo lo fossero vito e ragazzi